اكثر من 171 الف نازح جراء زلزال في شمال
سوريا ومانكوبو ادلب يناشدون العالم
للتدخل
لانقاذ التركيه تنجح في انتشار ثلاثه
ناجين من تحت الانقاض بعد 11 يوما من
الزلزال
قتلى في قصف روسي على باخموت شرق اوكرانيا
وقائد فاجنري يحمل قاده روسيا
في المدينه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في نشاط جديد ومفصله من
العربيه نبدا نشره من شمال سوريا حيث
ترتفع استغاثه المتضررين من الزلزال هناك
لارسال المساعدات وذلك بعد 11 يوما على
الكارثه مراسل العربيه افاد بدخول حوالي
650 شاحنه وسبع وسبعين طائره تحمل مساعدات
عبر جميع المنافذ الجويه والمعاب الخارجيه
مع كل من تركيا والاردن ولبنان والعراق
وايضا عبر المعابر الداخليه مع مناطق
الاداره الكرديه ومن المنتظر حسب مراسل
العربيه دخول اثنتين وثلاثين شاحنه تابعه
لامم المتحده من معبر باب الهواء اليوم
الجمعه
[موسيقى]
قالت منظمه تطوعيه تسمى منسق استجابه
سوريا ان عدد نازحين جراء زلزال شمال غرب
سوريا
171000 و 843 شخصا في حصيله غير نهائيه
واكدت المنظمه ان المساعدات الامميه ما
زالت ضمن حدود الدنيا مشيره الى ان عدد
الشاحنات لم يتجاوز خلال اسبوع واحد
واربعه عشره شاحنه وان ثلاثه وتسعين في
المئه منها دخل عبر معبر باب الهوى رغم
افتتاح معبرين اضافيين واوضحت المنظمه انه
من المتوقع دخول 24 شاحنه امميه من مع
بريبه بالهوى وبالسلامه منظمه منسق
استجابه سوريا كما تسمى دانت تاخر وصول
المساعدات الامميه مشيره الى انها لم
تتجاوز 25% من مجمل المساعدات التي دخلت
الشمال غرب البلاد
هذا واحتج متطوعون في شمال غرب سوريا على
قله المساعدات وضعف الاستجابه من المنظمات
الدوليه بعد زلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
المنطقه وقال متطوعون في المناطق التي
تعاني من اندلاع الحرب في سوريا وخروجها
عن سيطره النظام السوري ان قله المساعدات
تسبب ضارا اضافيا لملايين السوريين
من طالب نحنا باغاثه المتضررين والمنكوبين
بهذول بهذه الفاجعه تاخروا عليهم
بالاستجابه الاولى عم نخبرهم لا يتاخروا
عليهم بالاستجابه الثاني الناس حاليا
متضرره جدا بالعراء دون غذاء دون ماوى دون
اي مقومات للعيش هذا البناء يتكلم عن
تخاذل الامم برمته عن مساعده هذا الشعب
كما نقول في كشعب سوري لدينا مثل معروف
الميت لا يوحي ميت ولكن الشعب السوري قد
اثبت العكس واحيا نفسه بنفسه
فنحن بتمنى انه بس هلا شوي تاجيل مشان
المدارس نحن هلا باركين فيها لانه ما
عندنا بيوت يعني هلا صفينا ان احنا بس
بالمدارس لنا يعني هلا بيوت نستقر فيها
طاول طاوله بدايه تتهبطت يعني
بدنا سكن نرجع على البيوت اللي بده يعطونا
اياها عشان نامن الاطفال انه ترجع المدارس
هلا الفحوصات شوي يعني كلها تتاجل شوي
المدارس مشان هالاطفال
افادت مصادر العربيه بانهيار مبنى في ريفي
حلب جراء هزه ارضيه الليله الماضيه مشيره
الى وجود عالقين تحت الانقاض وكان المركز
الاورو متوسطي زلازل انه تم تسجيله هزه
ارضيه بقوه خمس درجات فاصله اثنين على
مقياس ريختر في سواحل اقليم اسكندرون وهي
الهزه التي شعر بها سكان حلب والنادقيه
وادلب وحماه وحمص والساحل السوري الى جانب
سكان مناطق لبنان الشماليه
مشاهدينا من منبج ينضم الينا ورسائل
العربيه جماعه اهلا بك جمعه وما الذي رشح
من التفاصيل حول انهيار هذا المبنى في حلب
بفعل الهزه الارتداديه التي حدثت ليله امس
في الحقيقه كانت هناك هزتان ارتداديتان
شهر السكان في مناطق شمال غرب حلب وادلب
وايضا في مدن اللاذقيه وحمى
وجبله نتيجه هذا الزلزاء يعني هذه الهزات
واحده منها كانت قويه خمسه فاصله اربعه
درجات على مقياس ريختر يعني الالاف من
الناس خرجوا من
المنازل الى الشوارع وباتو الليله في
السيارات او حتى في في الشوارع لكن نحن لم
نسجل انهيار اي مباني سواء في حلب اول
اللاذقيه انما تضرر بعض من المباني خاصه
في اعزاز والباب وجرابلس
اللاذقيه تشققات في هذه المباني وتضرر لكن
لم يسجل يعني سقوط اي مباني تحديدا في
مدينه حلب نحن نتاكد من المعلومات الوارده
عن يعني انهيار هذا المبنى ووجود على تحت
الانقاب طيب جمعه بقيه المناطق المنكوبه
هل من مؤشرات على
امكانيه تحسن الاوضاع بعد ارتفاع معدل
المساعدات الى هذه المناطق من جهه مختلفه
يعني حاليا بعض الفرق الدوليه خاصه التي
كانت تعمل في مناطق النظام حاصل والروسيه
انهت اعمال البحث عن جثث بشكل كامل طبعا
يعني اعمال البحث عن الجثث والانقاذ
تقريبا متوقفه وتعتمد على بلاغات الاهالي
في حال حدوث يعني في حال وجود جثث فيما
بين تحت ما بين مدمره تتوجه الفرق بمعنى
اننا اليوم قد يعني نكون امام اعلان رسمي
على الطرفين المعارضه ونظام بانهاء اعمال
البحث عن الجثث لانه فرق الدفاع
والانقاذ والفرق الاخرى توجه الان كل
اهتماماتها الى مساعده المنكوبين توزيع
المساعدات الغذائيه نصب خيم تهيئه ارضيه
مخيمات جديده محاوله يعني اعاده تهيئه
مياه المياه الشرب والمجال الصرف الصحي
والامور التي تضررت من الزلزال بشكل عام
يعني وضع المساعدات مقبول بسبب تدفقها من
عدد كبير من المعابر وايضا من المنافذ
الجويه لكنها لا يمكن ان تسد احتياجات
حوالي 400 الف شخص حاليا في كل مناطق
سوريا بدون ماوى ملايين المتضررين بشكل
مباشره وغير مباشر لاسيما وان يعني لا
النظام ولا حتى المعارضه تسمح بعوده يعني
الاهالي الى
يعني الى الاحياء والى الى المباني
المتضرره وحتى الان لا يوجد تقييم حقيقي
للمباني المتضرره وبالتالي لا يسمح لي
الاهالي بالعوده اليها هؤلاء الالاف منهم
حتى ليله امس كانوا يباتون في العراء وفي
الشوارع وفي الحدائق العامه حتى الذين
يعني لم يتضرروا بشكل مباشر او منازلهم لا
تنظر بشكل مباشر لا يسمح لانه احياء كامله
تم اخراجها ولا يوجد اي تقييم للمباني
سواء كان صالحه للعوده او غير صالحه
سيرتفي بهذا القدر شكرا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل من منبج كنت معنا
مراسل العربيه جماعه كاش تحياتي جمعه
رغم الكثير من الالم الذي رافق وقوع زلزال
بعض الحكايات تحتمل نهايات سعيده فاطمه
التي اصيبت بكسر في الرقبه في ادلب تسبب
باصابتها بشان رباعي ثماني نفس بالتعافي
بعد خضوعها لعمليه جراحيه لكن الامر
الاكبر في نقله عن العلاج بالخاري بسبب
حالهها الخطيره
رغم الالم يبقى هناك امل بالنجاه من
وضعيات صحيه سببها الزلزال الطفله فاطمه
ابنه ال15 عاما اصيبت بشلل رباعي نتج عن
كسر في احدى فقرات الرقبه خلال الزلزال
واجريت لها عمليه في مستشفى ادلب المركزي
جبناها الساعه خمسه الصبح يوم الكارثه يوم
الزلزال كانت صاحي وتغيب عن الوعي جبناها
على المشفى قالوا لنا تاني يوم الصبح في
شلل بالاطراف الاربعه عند فقره مكسوره
[موسيقى]
كابوس شلل الرباعي بدا يتلاشى مع اول
حركات اصابع يدي فاطمه عقب العمليه التي
اجريت لها وسط نقص كبير في التجهيزات
والمعدات الطبيه طبعا المريض لديها قصه
على المشفى في حاله شلل رباعي تم اجراء
عمل جراحي للكوربكتومي
[موسيقى]
المكسوره الضغط على النخاع الشوكي
وتعويضها فقره صناعيه مع صفيحه
الامل بشفاء هذه الحالات بحسب المختصين
ضعيف وغالبا يتم تحويلها الى تركيا بسبب
الحاجه لمستلزمات متقدمه بهيك حالات امل
ضعيف صراحه احنا
احنا مرضى عاده هيك حالات ممكن تتحول على
على تركيا انه بسبب انه انه
عدم توفر مستلزمات مثلا عمل جراحي بس هذه
الحاله ان شاء الله يعني ضمن التحسن من
العمليات النوعيه ان شاء الله كون في
كونفيد كان فيه تحسن يعني ملموس ان شاء
الله بالنسبه للمريضه
وبانتظار نهايه سعيده لقصه فاطمه يبقى
التشبث بالامل بتعافها وتجاوبها مع العلاج
احد الادوات الى حين وقوفها على قدميها
مجددا
مع الابقاء على الامل بالتئام جراح اخرى
قال منسق الامم المتحده الاقليمي للشؤون
الانساني للازمه السوريه مهند هادي ان
المنظمه تواجه صعوبه في احصاء النازحين
لكثره اعدادهم شمالا غرب سوريا
نامل ان لا يرتفع عدد الضحايا كثيرا ولكن
مما نراه ونسمعه لا يمنحنا الدمار الذي
خلفه ذلك الزلزال في الحقيقه الكثير من
الامل في ان تكون هذه نهايه الامر قبل ان
يبدا الزلزال كان هناك حوالي اربعه ملايين
ومائه الف شخص بحاجه الى المساعده في شمال
غرب سوريا كثير منهم نازحون الان ومع
تزايد هذا العدد نجد صعوبه كبيره في تحديد
عدد الاشخاص الذين نزحوا مجددا بسبب
الزلزال لكن يمكنني ان اؤكد لكم ان الامم
المتحده وشركائها يبذلون قصار جهدهم
لتوفير الماوى المؤقت لهؤلاء الاشخاص
بالاضافه الى المساعدات الاخرى المطلوبه
وفي اول كلمه له حول تداعيات زلزال الذي
ضرب تركيا وسوريا قال رئيس النظام السوري
بشار الاسد ان المرافق السوريه لم تكن
مهيئه للتعامل مع مثل هذه الكارثه كان حجم
تلك الكارثه والمهام المناطق بنا جميعا
اكبر بكثير من الامكانيات المتاحه
لكننا تمكن مجتمعنا من القيام به بافراده
ومؤسساته كان ايضا اكبر بكثير من
الامكانيات المتاحه ليس بسبب الحرب
والحصار فقط وانما لان سوريا لم تكن منطقه
زلازل مدمره على امتداد قرنين ونصف
في تركيا افادت وسائل اعلام محليه بان فرق
الاغاثه في هاتاي تمكنت من انقاذ شابين
بعد قضائهما اكثر من 2161 ساعه تحت
الانقاض
الله الله اكبر
الله اكبر
وقبل هذه العمليه بقليل انتشرت فرق
الانقاذ طفلا عمره نحو 12 عاما من تحت
الانقاض في ولايه هاتاي وذلك بعد 260 ساعه
من الزلزال
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
ومع انتشار مئات المخيمات المستحدثه مؤخرا
لاواء متضرري زلزال في تركيا بدات الحكومه
التركيه مشاريع عديده لبناء مساكن مؤقته
رصد احد المشاريع في التقرير التالي
ضمن مسائل حكومه التركيه لتوفير مساكن
مؤقته لمتضرري الزلزال بدات هنا اعمال
تشييد 300 منزل مسبق الصنع في مدينه
اصلاحيه بولايه غاز عنتاب جنوب تركيا هذه
المنازل ستستوعب 300 عائله تقيم حاليا في
خيام قدمتها هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث
التركيه افاد من المتوقع ان يتم تسليم هذه
المنازل لاصحابها في غضون 20 يوما كحد
اقصى هذا المشروع ليس الوحيد من نوعه بل
هناك مشاريع مشابهه هنا في مدينه اصلاحيه
او في بقيه المناطق المنكوبه ويعتبر هذا
المشروع احد الحلول المؤقته التي طرحتها
الحكومه التركيه كحل بديل للسكان
المتضررين من الزلزال لحين الانتهاء من
اعمال اعاده الاعمار وبناء المساكن
الجديده من مدينه اصلاحيه في ولايه غازي
عنتاب زيدان زنجلو
مستمرا مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
بعد ارتفاع اسعارها بشكل جنوني حملات على
شبكه التواصل في مصر تدعو لمقاطعه اللحوم
والدواجن
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد نواصل نشره من
تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث اعلن حاكم
مدينه سيفو العاصمه شبه جزيره القرم ان
اعلن ان قوات الدفاع الجوي الروسي اسقطت
مسيره اوكرانيه عند اقترابها من محطه
للطاقه الحراريه واشار في بيان له الى ان
عمليه التصدي للمسير الاوكرانيه لم تخلف
اي اضرار على المحطه وانها تعمل بشكل
طبيعي
هذا والتواصل معركه اوكرانيا وسط توقعات
قائد مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه بالسيطره على
المدينه في مارس
مشيرا الى ان البطء في تقدم القوات
الروسيه يرجع الى البيروقراطيه العسكريه
في انتقاد صريح لقاده في الجيش الروسي
واضاف بريكوجين ان السيطره على باخم
تستوجب قطع كل طرق الامدادات الاوكرانيه
واعتبر انه لولا البيروقراطي العسكري
الرهيبه لا تمت السيطره على باقمت على حد
وصفه هذا وقال مكتب المدعي العام
الاوكراني من جهته ان القصف الروسي على
بخمس في مقاطعه دونيسك اسفر عن مقتل خمسه
اشخاص واصابه تسعه اخرين
الحرب في اوكرانيا اقتربت من اكمال عامها
الاول القتال يستمر في الارض كما في
السماء موسكو دخلت باستراتيجيه اساسها دحر
الجيش الاوكراني في وقت قياسي باستخدام
مختلف الاسلحه
لكن لا احد انتصر في المعركه
بوتين اعتمد على وابل من الصواريخ
الباليستيه مع الاحتفاظ بطائراته في بنك
الاحتياط طائرات باهضه التكلفه كصوخوي 35
في مرحله اخرى اعتمدت روسيا على المسيرات
الايرانيه الرخيصه الثمن لضرب البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه في المقابل ردت
اوكرانيا جوا من خلال دمج انظمه الدفاع
الجوي الغربيه في جيشها ما ادى الى تحسين
ادائه كصواريخ باتريوت ونسانس 300 وعلى
الرغم من ذلك يؤكد خبراء ان معركه السماء
ما تزال متوازنه الى حد كبير في الفتره
الحاليه بالغالب ولا مغلوب لكن مخاوف تسود
من ان الكريملين قد يحاول اغراق الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه بالقاذفات والطائرات
المقاتله والمروحيه الهجوميه وكذلك
بالصواريخ في محاوله لايمالات كفه الحرب
لصالح موسكو بلال البشتين العربيه
من المقرر ان ينطلق اليوم مؤتمر ميونخ
الامن في المانيا لبحث ملفات الامن حيث
تطغى الحرب الاوكرانيه على المشهد في هذا
الاطار مشاهدينا ينتظر ان يلقي مسؤولون
اوكرانيون كلمه في المؤتمر بحضور رؤساء
وزعماء منهم المستشار الالماني والرئيس
الفرنسي
وعدد من المسؤولين من حول العالم المؤتمر
في نسخته الحاليه لا تحضره روسيا ولا
ايران
في ايران تجددت المسيرات الاحتجاجيه
المناهضه للنظام في عده احياء بالعاصمه
الايرانيه طهران ومدن ايرانيه كبيره اخرى
بما في ذلك مشهد واصفهان كما اشار
التقارير الى ان مجموعه من المواطنين
تجمعوا فكره
احتجاجيه باشعال النار وترديد شعار الموت
[موسيقى]
هددت كوريا الشماليه بتوجيه رد قوي غير
مسبوق في حال مضت الولايات المتحده وكوريا
الجنوبيه في تنفيذ مناورات عسكريه مشتركه
وحضرت من زياده حجم التوتر بسبب هذه
المناورات متهمه
بتدمير السلام والاستقرار عمدا عبر ما
وصفته بالاحتجاجات العسكريه
في السودان قال رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي عبد الفتاح البرهاني ان الجيش
وافق على الاتفاق الايطالي ويدعمه عن
قناعه مضيفا ان الاتفاق يعالج مشاكل
البلاد ودع البرهان قوى الحريه والتغيير
الى ضروره القبول بالجلوس مع القوى
السياسيه الاخرى
في قياده القوات المسلحه وفي قياده الدوله
[موسيقى]
ودعمنا لاتفاق الاطار
الخرطوم
احنا كجيش لانه هذا الاتفاق الايطالي بعد
مشاكل السودان نحن عشان المركز بتاع
الحريه والتغيير ولكن الوطنيه نحن اللي
قلناه عشان السودان والان مع زوج ما
الحريه والتغيير
مع السودان مع السودانيين
يعني
نحن داعمين هذا الاتفاق ما على شان اي فئه
قاعد اعمله لانه في وحيات حقيقيه تطلعنا
مهم جدا نحن عسكريين بيهم الليل
في القوات المسلحه
[موسيقى]
اذا في كلام واضح منصف المقنع
الحركات المسلحه المسلحه نحن
حكومه نحن همنا واحد ليش وطني ليش يدافع
عن السودان ويحمي على
لكن خلال هذا الكلام ما حيكون مقبول ولا
في ولا
بتتخيل المهم
انت غلطان
ونشر مشاهدينا الى هذا الخبر العاجل حيث
دعت الحكومه الاوكرانيه مواطنيها الى
اخلاء مدينه باخموت على الفور بالعوده الى
سياق نشاطنا بعد الارتفاع الكبير في اسعار
اللحوم والدواجن في مصر انطلقت عده حملات
على صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي تدعو
للمقاطعه كنوع من العقاب ليشع التجار
تفاصيل هذه الحملات هو ردود الفعل بشانها
نتابعها في التقرير التالي
نحن الان داخل احد منافذ لبيع السلع
الغذائيه المعروفه باسم اهلا رمضان هذه
المنافذ التي تم افتتاحها بدايه شهر يناير
الماضي ومن المفترض ان تستمر حتى نهايه
رمضان تهدف لتوفير السلع باسعار مخفضه
تخفيفا عن كاهل للمواطنين الاقبال بدا
كبيرا داخل اروقه المنفذ مواطنون من كافه
الشرائح الاجتماعيه جاءوا للاستفاده من
العروض الاقبال كان مكثفا على اللحوم
والدواجن التي تشهد ارتفاعا كبيرا في
اسعارها اللحمه ب 240 بره هنا واخذاها ب
160 وحلوه السعر عالي بره جدا هنا في في
تخفيضات حلوه في حاجات وحاجات لا اطلاقوا
هذه المبادرات يتزامن مع دعوات على صفحات
التواصل الاجتماعي لمقاطعه اللحوم
والدواجن بسبب زياده الجنونيه في اسعارها
مواطنون استجابوا لهذه الدعوات على امل ان
تنجح في اجبار التجار على تخفيض الاسعار
انا مع المقاطعه مره باتعه ضد الفراخ وضد
اللحمه ده انت بتروح تشتري الكيلو اللحمه
النهارده يقول لك ب 65 تاني يوم تلاقيه ب
70 على طول اصحابه محاليل جزاره اعترفوا
بنجاح حملات المقاطعه لكنهم برروا ارتفاع
اسعار اللحوم باسباب خارجه عن ارادتهم انا
كجزره اهو انا مع المقاطعه بس مش لوحدي
لازم ينزل قرار بقفل الجزاره على الاقل مش
اقل من 30 يوم اللي عنده عجل واللي بيربي
والناس اللي مخبيه
بهايمها في المزارع ومش في الغلا كل ده
ياكل على حسابه كل بقى ما فيش جزاره اكل
بقى على حسابك غصبا عنه هيبيع الفتره
الاخيره شهدت اغلاقا لبعض محالي بيع
الدواجن واللحوم اما بسبب نجاح حملات
المقاطعه او لعدم قدره المواطنين على
الشراء في ظل زياده الاسعار احمد عثمان
العربيه القاهره
في نهايه النصر مشاهدينا نذكر بابرز
العناوين
اكثر من 171 الف نازح جراء زلزال في شمال
سوريا ومنكوب ادلب يناشدون العالم
للتدخلات الصف الثالث
التركيه تنجح في انتشار ثلاثه
قتلى بقصف روسي على باخمه شرق اوكرانيا
وقائد فارغنر يحمل قادتها روق قاده روس
مسؤوليه تاخر حسم المعركه في المدينه
نهايه هذه النص المشاهدين في امان الله
[موسيقى]